[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
en Reino Unido un país donde algunos
niños y jóvenes tienen una privilegiada
opción de estudio y es la implementación
de la realidad virtual y el metaverso en
sus clases en el día a día con visores
los estudiantes de la readam House
School de bershire pueden sumergirse en
un corazón humano algo que para muchos
hace una clase de biología más
interesante o también manipular con sus
manos los planetas del sistema solar
esas son solo algunas de las lecciones
interactivas que ofrece el plan de
estudios
la retención es fantástica una vez que
experimentan algo lo recordarán y hay
una comprensión más profunda Porque
pueden manipular los objetos pueden
verlos desde todos los ángulos entender
cómo funcionan Cuál es el objetivo
aprendimos sobre el sistema solar
planetas que es una estrella que es un
satélite la biología también se adapta
muy bien al metaverso porque podemos
explorar cosas como una célula y
entender cómo funcionan las cosas en
términos de difusión o de funcionamiento
interno
todo esto hace parte del proyecto
metaverse School que está siendo
desarrollado por el grupo inspired
education y realizan el piloto en 84
colegios de 24 países no obstante la
intención es que todos los niños del
mundo puedan acceder a este plan de
estudios
algunas de las cosas más impresionantes
que podemos hacer son experimentos que
de otra manera serían imposibles o muy
peligrosos en las clases por ejemplo
viajar al espacio exterior pararnos en
la superficie de la luna pero también
podemos usarlo en materias como
geografía para tener viajes instantáneos
a otras partes del mundo lo usamos en
historia para volver en el tiempo
experimentar cosas como durante la
Segunda Guerra Mundial seguimos con
temas de aprendizaje Pero esta vez vamos
a conocer la aplicación eilem que fue
premiada con el premio europeo
carlomagno de la juventud su propósito
Es acelerar la integración de migrantes
mediante juegos y guías para que
aprendan el idioma de acogida de forma
dinámica y tengan herramientas para
acabar con las barreras culturales
es una aplicación hecha por refugiados y
demandantes de asilo para refugiados y
demandantes de asilo les ofrecemos un
aprendizaje de idiomas hecho a medida
para ayudarles a integrarse en su nueva
sociedad de una forma más sencilla
puedes usarlo cuando vas al hospital
para ir a comprar cuando coges el bus o
el tranvía cuando rellenas un documento
como refugiado cuando pides comida
y si por ejemplo el refugio es musulmán
también puede pedir comida jalar Así que
está muy personalizado en base a la
experiencia de cada refugiado
la plataforma fue desarrollada tras
entrevistar a refugiados en Europa y en
medio oriente y fue con esas respuestas
que se crearon los juegos y estrategias
según sus necesidades específicas los
creadores también llaman a los locales
para descargarla para aumentar los lazos
con los solicitantes de asilo y
refugiados
vamos ahora Argentina donde un grupo de
paleontólogos terminó una investigación
de cinco años luego de descubrir una
nueva especie de un gigantesco
dinosaurio en la Patagonia esta zona del
país se caracteriza por los múltiples
hallazgos de fósiles que han permitido
científicos de todo el mundo realizar
descubrimientos sobre el pasado de la
tierra Andrés triviño tiene los detalles
Argentina realiza un hallazgo de unos 90
millones de años un grupo de
paleontólogos descubrió los restos de
una especie gigantesca de un dinosaurio
herbívoro de cuello largo en la región
de la Patagonia al sur del país siendo
una de las bestias más grandes jamás
descubiertas enchucaros saurus medía
cerca de 30 metros de largo esto lo
sabemos gracias a los restos que pudimos
encontrar de este de este dinosaurio que
incluyen partes del miembro anterior del
de la mano digamos de este animal como
del miembro posterior y algunos
elementos de la cadera
Es llamativo realmente el tamaño este
animal que el hueso del fémur el hueso
que articula la cadera con con el pie
mide más de un metro 90 de alto el
hallazgo en la reserva natural pueblo
blanco sucedió en 2018 y recientemente
fue terminada la investigación
paleontológica chucarosaurios
diripiendas significa lagarto fuerte y
revuelto y habría vivido durante la
época del cretácico superior junto a
depredadores peces y tortugas marinas la
Patagonia fue el hogar de gigantescos
dinosaurios como el colosal patagotitan
mayorum el más grande descubierto hasta
ahora en el mundo Argentina tiene una
una cuestión muy positiva para nosotros
somos paleontólogos de que es uno es el
paraíso de la paleontología porque debes
en la actualidad debemos tener más de
140 especies Y eso nos ubica por lo
menos en el top 3 del mundo
ahora los restos del Dinosaurio serán
expuestos al público en la provincia de
Río negro
cerramos con el que ha sido calificado
como el proyecto de escaneo submarino
más grande de la historia se trata de un
modelo 3D en tamaño Real del Titanic
cuyos datos Fueron recopilados por dos
sumergibles llamados Romeo y Julieta
esto durante una expedición de seis
semanas en el lugar del naufragio en el
Atlántico Norte La Misión recolectó un
enorme cantidad de datos a 3.800 metros
debajo de la superficie y según los
responsables permite reescribir por
completo la comprensión del desastre
ocurrido en 1912 que dejó más de 1500
fallecidos así llegamos al final de este
espacio a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]